[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM LEVIN: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
My name is Adam Levin, and
I'm a product marketing
manager for Cloud Spanner.
Today I'm here to
talk to you about,
"Is Cloud Spanner the
right database for you?"
You can ask questions at
any time on the platform.
And Googlers are on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started.
There we go.
So today we've got
a brief agenda.
We're going to go through
a brief overview of what
Cloud Spanner is.
We'll talk a little bit about
the philosophy behind Cloud
Spanner and what differentiates
it from a philosophical
and from a historical context
from the rest of the relational
and non-relational databases
out there on the market today.
We'll also talk a bit about,
today, what workloads fit best,
and also, today, what
workloads fit less well.
And I emphasize today, because
we're constantly rolling out
new features on Cloud Spanner
to improve the experience
and provide enhanced
functionality.
Then we'll talk about
common misconceptions
with the service, common issues.
And finally, we will tackle
some common questions
before getting to our Q&A.
So let's get started.
So what is Cloud Spanner?
And we always like to say, great
apps run on great databases.
And we think Cloud Spanner
is a great database.
So Cloud Spanner is the only
enterprise-grade, globally
distributed, and strongly
consistent database service
built for the cloud
specifically to combine
the benefits of relational
database structure
with non-relational
database scale.
It's unique in the marketplace
in that it combines
transactions, SQL query,
and relational structure
with the scalability
you typically
associate with non-relational
or NoSQL databases.
Databases are part
of every application.
So it's very important to
pick the right database
for your application.
So there are a few things that
are tricky about databases
that Cloud Spanner
attempts to solve.
The first has to do with scale.
Most databases today are
only vertically scalable.
You can add more
CPU memory or disk,
but that incurs
downtime typically.
You can also shard
your database,
but that incurs
operational complexity
and has a manageability
aspect that's difficult.
Next, operations are tricky.
You can have hardware
that breaks down,
OS and software patches
that need to be applied.
There are end-of-life
issues with software
that need to be managed
and accounted for.
And all of those
also incur downtime.
Last, you always constantly
need to tweak the performance
of the database to
get the most out of it
and get everything
that you want to be
able to accomplish with that.
And last, there's the
infamous rebuilding
of indexes, which is a
dreaded task by a lot of DBAs.
It also could incur downtime.
Replication is another
area that's tricky.
Making sure all copies of
the data are up to date
across different replicas,
providing read-only replicas
for reducing latency,
and increasing
the throughput of
your application,
as well as ensuring disaster
recovery using replication.
All those are very tricky
things to get right.
Keeping them in
sync is non-trivial,
and there's always a finite
replication delay when
you try to do this on your own.
Last, transactions, particularly
around read/write transactions,
are hard to do when you are
sharding and replicating
your database.
Ensuring strong consistency
makes a developer's life
much simpler, because they
can rely on strong consistency
instead of having to
write in application logic
to deal with the constraints
around eventual consistency.
So all four of these activities
make databases tricky today.
Cloud Spanner is the first
and only relational database
that's globally
consistent, horizontally
scalable, and fully managed.
So you don't have to compromise.
You don't have to
make trade-offs
to get all of these aspects
around performance, scale, SQL,
and manageability.
With Cloud Spanner, you enjoy
all the traditional benefits
of a SQL database;
transactions, high availability,
schema changes without
downtime, and SQL queries.
But unlike many
relational databases,
Cloud Spanner scales
horizontally from one
to thousands of servers, an
arbitrarily large number.
With fully automatic data
replication and server
redundancy, Cloud
Spanner delivers up
to five nines of availability
in multi-region instances
and four nines of availability
in regional instances.
In fact, Google's
internal Spanner instance
has been handling millions
of queries per second
from many Google
services for years.
We've been running various
services on Spanner
for many, many years.
So it's battle-tested,
and tried and true.
Cloud Spanner combines
relational semantics
found in traditional
relational databases
with horizontal scale associated
with non-relational databases.
Cloud Spanner is the
no-compromise database.
You can have your
cake and eat it, too.
Many other databases
out there today
approximate aspects of what
Cloud Spanner enables, but they
don't quite fully get there.
And you see in the market
today lots of existing database
services adding on
additional features
to try to approximate what
Cloud Spanner achieves,
but Cloud Spanner solves these
fundamentally challenging
problems at the core.
So these challenges
are not being addressed
as add-ons, but as something
that's fundamental to what
the database does.
Cloud Spanner has
relational semantics
with schemas, enforced data
types, strong consistency,
and ACID transactions across
rows, tables, regions.
SQL query using ANSI
2011 SQL with extensions.
You also get all this
with horizontal scale
so you can scale to arbitrary
large database sizes.
So combining
relational semantics
and horizontal scale all in
one easy-to-use database.
So let's take a step
back a little bit.
Let's talk a little bit
about the philosophy
of Cloud Spanner.
And it's super
important to understand
the philosophy of
Cloud Spanner in order
to understand the way it works.
And that will help determine
if Cloud Spanner is
the right database
for your application.
So first and foremost,
with Cloud Spanner,
the application is in
control of its database.
The database is there
to store the data,
and to ensure that
data is strongly
consistent and replicated
and always available.
In traditional
relational databases,
the database was in
control of the data,
enforcing value constraints,
doing data verification
with triggers and stored procs
and very fine-grained ACLs.
With Cloud Spanner, all
of that application logic
is pushed into the application.
You have to consider that
when moving from one database
to Cloud Spanner.
So with Cloud Spanner,
the application
determines what's valid,
such as not null constraints
and unique indexes being
controlled with Spanner.
And then there is no
real business logic
within the database layer.
So the application has
to control that and use
Cloud Spanner for
what it is built for,
which is storing data.
So let's dive into the
implications of this philosophy
and what it means
for an application
to be in control
and the database
to do things that
databases should be doing.
So what workloads fit
best with Cloud Spanner?
And first and foremost, sharded
relational database systems,
such as sharded MySQL.
Any time where you have a
sharded relational database
that is difficult to maintain,
that is becoming unwieldy,
that's a perfect fit for moving
to Cloud Spanner, because Cloud
Spanner gives you that scale
and that familiar relational
semantics and that SQL
queryability, but it removes
all of the management
overhead, all
of the operational headaches
associated with sharded MySQL
and manually sharding.
And it's just sort of
a natural progression.
And even in the original reasons
why Cloud Spanner was built
was because Google was using
a sharded MySQL database
and realized that it was just
too difficult to continue
to maintain that.
So that was one of the
primary drivers for building
Spanner in the first place.
The second reason and the second
workload that fits really well
with Cloud Spanner
is anytime you
have scalable relational
data and you're running out
of headroom in your
relational database
and you're considering moving
towards a NoSQL database,
or a non-relational store.
And when you move to a
non-relational database,
you often have to give up.
You often have to
make a compromise.
make a trade-off.
And whether that's in terms
of consistency, manageability,
transactions, or any
number of things,
people are willing to
make that trade-off often
in order to get scale as
their application grows.
But with Cloud
Spanner, you don't
have to make that trade-off.
You can get the scale
you need, as well as
the familiar
relational semantics.
Last, manageability in HA.
If you just want to get out
of the business of managing
your databases, Cloud
Spanner is a great fit.
It's a very easy-to-use
system, particularly
for how complicated
it is under the hood.
We abstract away all of the
operations of the database.
So there's no such thing
as planned downtime
with Cloud Spanner.
Everything is an
online operation.
All patching and
upgrades are online.
Index rebuilds are online.
Adding an index, schema
changes, all of that
is an online operation.
And so you can get out of
the business of managing.
The same is true for
providing high availability.
Cloud Spanner provides
that out of the box.
We replicate your data
multiple ways depending
on the configuration
that you choose
and create when you set up
your Cloud Spanner instance.
But we handle that
all for you so you
don't have to worry about it.
And we provide SLAs,
high availability SLAs,
to guarantee that your
data will always be there.
Next is multi-region.
With Cloud Spanner you can
write once and have the database
automatically replicate your
data to multiple regions.
Whether that's for
high availability
or for reducing
read latency, that
depends on the needs
of your application.
We have multiple multi-region
configurations for you
to choose from, depending on
the needs of your application.
And we're always adding new
ones based on customer demand.
After saying that,
though, most customers
still use regional
instances today,
because you get the
high availability.
We replicate your
data to multiple zones
within a given region.
And most customers are using
regional instances today,
but it's nice to know that
multi-region instances are
available should you need them.
So let's take a look at where
Cloud Spanner is available.
So as I mentioned,
most commonly used
are regional configurations.
We have Cloud Spanner
available in many, many GCP
regions across the globe.
And we're always
rolling out new regions.
So for instance, just
last week with the launch
of the new Hong Kong
region, Cloud Spanner
was available in Hong Kong.
And we'll be announcing
new regions again
in the near future where
Cloud Spanner is available.
And so wherever
your application is,
there's a Cloud Spanner instance
available to you nearby.
Regional configurations are what
the majority of customers use.
They put their
application workload
in the same region as
the Spanner instance
to reduce latency.
And then your data is
spread over several zones
within the region so that the
app has the same availability
as the database.
And that's important
to remember.
The database is just
one particular part
of your application, one
place where availability is.
But if your app goes down, and
the database is still there,
then users still can
use your application.
So as I mentioned, regional
instances have four nines SLA.
And coming soon, we'll
be adding new regions.
So we have a number of
multi-region configurations
depending on where your
application users are
and what your needs are.
So this first one,
nam3, it's called,
is multi-region configuration
on the East Coast of the United
States in north Virginia
and South Carolina.
And multi-region instances
are a bit more expensive
than regional instances,
but you do get
an extra nine of availability.
So with all these
multi-region configurations
that I'll go through, you get
five nines of availability.
That's less than five
minutes of downtime
per year, which is
pretty extraordinary,
considering what it takes to get
that level of high availability
with an on-premises database
and to guarantee that level
of high availability.
So this is the first
multi-region configuration.
We also have another North
America configuration
that has two
read-write regions, one
in South Carolina, one in Iowa.
And then it also has
two read-only regions;
one in Oregon, and one
in our new LA region.
And so this configuration
is great for data
that you need
replicated across the US
for an app that is used
predominantly in North America.
But because of the
Google network,
it could also serve data
at pretty fast speeds
across any ocean.
And as your data is replicated
on both sides of the country,
or both sides of the US,
it has closer proximity
to cables crossing the Pacific
as well as the Atlantic.
There's also a
multi-region configuration
in Europe with read-write
replicas in the Netherlands
and Belgium for
European-centric workloads.
And this provides five
nines of availability
while still keeping
your data in Europe.
So that's a great option for
customers based out of Europe.
And last is a global
configuration.
So this configuration has
the read-write regions
within the United States,
in Iowa and Oklahoma,
and then read-only regions
in Europe and Asia.
So for a truly
global applications,
this configuration
is perfect for you.
Now, it's really
interesting to think about
whether you need a
multi-region configuration,
or you just need multiple
regional configurations.
And that really depends on
the needs of your application
and what you're
trying to accomplish,
whether you're trying to
have your data replicated
around the world so you can
have very low latency data
access across the world, or
if you can sort of separate
your users out and
have each country
sort of operate separately.
And then you can use multiple
regional instances as opposed
to a global configuration or
multi-region configuration.
So the choice is up to
you, but Cloud Spanner
is here to support.
So let's talk a
little bit about when
Cloud Spanner fits less well.
And the next few slides
might seem negative.
I'm a marketer, but this is
not supposed to be negative.
I really want to be
honest with you all today
and provide insight into where
Cloud Spanner excels today
and where it may
require a little bit
more work to be able to use.
Because Cloud Spanner provides
relational semantics and scale,
it seems like the
perfect solution.
And it is for many workloads.
But there are a
few instances where
it may require a bit more
work and a bit more thought
on your part.
So the first is lift and shift.
And this really comes
down to the philosophy
of Cloud Spanner.
It's not a compatible database.
You can't just take a MySQL
application or database
and lift it up and put
it on Cloud Spanner.
It doesn't have compatibility.
It doesn't do some of the
things that MySQL does.
And for some
traditional databases
that may have 30
years of features
that have been added
over time, Cloud Spanner
doesn't have a lot
of those features,
because of the
philosophical differences
between Cloud Spanner and
traditional relational
databases.
So customers who have
a lot of business logic
in their database using
triggers, stored procedures,
have a hard time moving to
Cloud Spanner sometimes,
because they have to
take that business logic
and move it back
into the application.
The application is in
charge of business logic.
The application is
in charge of knowing
when something should happen.
The database is
there to store data,
and make sure it's
available, and make sure
that it's replicated.
So Cloud Spanner does not have
triggers and stored procedures.
This is not necessarily
a blocker, though.
Some customers see the benefit
of rewriting their code
to optimize it for the cloud.
And so it's sometimes
a great opportunity
to re-examine some
of the legacy code
that may exist in
your code base,
and then sort of modernize
it for a cloud design point.
The next is compatibility.
Customers who want
rapid lift and shift,
migrating to Cloud
Spanner may not
be a trivial task when you
just want to flip something up
to the cloud.
And so what we see
a lot of the times
is folks moving to something
like Cloud SQL PostgreS first,
and then modernizing over
time to get to Cloud Spanner.
This is certainly easier
today with the enhancements
that have been made around DML
and an upgraded JDBC driver.
But all of the tools and all
of the other ecosystem things
that you might rely on, you
need to take a look at that
and see what you rely on and
what your constraints are
when moving to Cloud Spanner.
And we're always adding new
drivers and new ORM tools,
and the rest of the ecosystem.
But just take a look and
see what's available today,
see what's on the
roadmap for tomorrow,
and see if there's a path that's
compatible with what you need.
And the last thing
I want to mention
is apps that need
super low latency,
Cloud Spanner isn't the
right choice for you.
That's not to say that
Cloud Spanner isn't fast.
It's very fast.
But when you're talking about
microsecond, nanosecond, very
low, single-digit
millisecond latency,
Cloud Spanner probably isn't
the right tool for that job.
Other services, like
Cloud Bigtable, or even
in-memory services, like
Cloud Memorystore for Redis
are probably the thing
you want to look at if you
need ultra low latency.
Cloud Spanner
provides low latency,
but not at that very low level.
You can also get very
sustained and consistent levels
of latency with Cloud
Spanner as you scale up,
which is one of
the nice features
that customers love about it.
As they add more nodes
to their instance
and their configuration, they
see the latency keep up and not
escalate as the load on
their database grows.
So those are some of
the key areas where
Cloud Spanner fits less well.
Let's talk about some of
the common misconceptions
around Cloud Spanner.
And this is really where we
get into the questions that
get asked around
Cloud Spanner a lot.
And it's funny,
because when people
start looking at Cloud
Spanner, most people
have the same common
set of questions.
And I want to
address those today.
The first is that, yes,
this is fully managed.
There is no software patching,
no upgrades, no downtime,
no index rebuilds,
no resharding,
and you can dynamically
scale up and down.
In fact, it only
takes four clicks
to create a Cloud
Spanner instance.
You just go into
the GCP console.
And you create your
Spanner instance.
You give it a name.
You pick how many
nodes you want.
You pick what configuration
type you want,
whether that's regional
and in what region,
or if you want a
multi-region instance.
And then you click Create.
And in a matter of seconds you
have a fully managed, fully
replicated, scalable database.
And what's really nice about
it is as your application needs
grow, you can just go
back into the console,
or you can also do it
programmatically as well,
and increase or decrease
the size of your instance.
You can just go in and click one
to however many times you need,
and get more throughput
for your instance.
And in a matter of seconds,
you have additional throughput.
It sometimes takes a couple
minutes for Cloud Spanner
to repartition and
balance out your data,
but this is something that
the database is always
doing on the back end anyways.
Repartitioning, resharding,
electing new leaders
within the system
on the back end
is something that is
constantly happening.
It's constantly going
on within the system.
It's not a failure event.
It's not a scale event.
This is just something that
the database is always doing.
So as you add more
nodes, it just says,
hey, I've got more nodes to add
to my Cloud Spanner instance,
and it balances the data out.
And that takes a
couple of minutes.
But compare that to what
it's like increasing capacity
on an on-premise
database where you
have to order capacity,
wait for it to arrive,
take it out of the box,
plug it in, set it up.
I mean, we're talking months.
Cloud Spanner gives
you this in minutes.
It's really a different type
of management experience.
And for operators who
want to be able to control
every single aspect
of the database
and know where every block
of data is stored on disk,
Cloud Spanner is fully managed.
So you're not going to get
that level of granularity
of control.
So it does require
a bit of a shift
in thinking around
what it is that you
spend your time on when it
comes to managing the database.
But as I'll get to in
the next couple slides,
there's still a lot to think
about and a lot to plan
for in using Cloud Spanner.
The next common misconception
is around strong consistency.
And this is really a
philosophical aspect
of Cloud Spanner as well.
This comes to improving
the developer experience.
Being able to rely
on strong consistency
is super important and super
powerful to a developer.
With a lot of sharded
databases, with a lot
of scale-out
databases, particularly
those that cover a
wide geographic area,
those databases use something
called eventual consistency.
Or maybe there are multiple
flavors of consistency,
but there aren't any that
offer strong consistency
across regions
like Cloud Spanner.
And when you have to reason
over eventual consistency,
you have to build in
complicated checks
into your application
code to say, hey,
is this a strong read?
Hey, is this an eventual read?
Is this the latest update?
Can I trust what this thing is?
With Cloud Spanner, everything
is a strongly consistent read.
You can do bounded stale reads
if you need to improve latency,
but your data is still
strongly consistent.
You're never going to get
anything that's out of order.
If your application
is OK with it,
you might just get something
that's a few seconds older,
but not out of order.
And so this is really
an enhanced version
of strong consistency
called external consistency,
where we talk about
external as being
able to look at an
external wall clock
and see what time something
happened within the database.
And that's really the foundation
of how Cloud Spanner works.
It relies on a combination
of software and hardware
to enable this low latency
synchronous replication.
So data is always
available on commit.
And writes happen
at super low latency
once a quorum of all
regions within an instance
have accepted the write.
And so this provides
a true ACID database
that spans multiple regions or
multiple zones within a region,
offering strong consistency.
And this is possible through the
high speed network that Google
has built out, as
well as relying
on a fully optimized stack,
including TrueTime, which you
may have heard about, which
uses atomic clocks and GPS
satellites to provide very,
very accurate and pinpoint time.
So different replicas that
span a wide geographic area
can still take the same time
and reduce the uncertainty
around when something happens.
So let's talk about a
couple common issues
that customers face when
moving to Cloud Spanner.
And the first is really
around key choice.
Your key choice is
super important.
Sequential timestamp-based keys
can cause hotspotting, which
can impede your performance.
So you want to be very
careful around that.
Random UUIDs or hashes
distribute the data better.
Some sort of composite around
random UUIDs work well, too.
So it's very important to think
through what schema you're
going to choose and your
schema design when moving
to Cloud Spanner.
And that's a bit of
a shift in thinking
from traditional
relational databases.
Next, as I mentioned
before, lack of triggers,
stored procedures,
and check constraints
mean that you have to move that
logic into the application.
So Not Null constraints
exist, and keys
are unique, and unique
column values via indexes.
But you need to
think through how
you get all of that
application logic out
and put that in your
application and use
the database for storing data.
A couple of common issues
also to just mention,
foreign key constraints
and on-delete cascades
only exist with parent-child
interleaved tables.
So Cloud Spanner has
an interesting concept
that's similar to a pre-join
called interleave tables, which
we don't have time to
get into in detail today,
but it allows you to
signal to the system
that you want data
physically stored next
to each other, physically
stored on the same split
within the database.
And that allows for data that's
commonly accessed together
to be accessed faster
than it would if it was
stored on a different split.
And that's just an
optimization, but something
to think through as you're
designing your Cloud Spanner
schema.
More common issues.
Indexes are tables too.
So you have the same
constraints for index keys
as you do for your
primary key, where
you don't want to just
use an incrementing value,
because that will
lead to hotspotting.
Next, your primary
key is the row ID.
So it uniquely
identifies the row,
and it's used to determine
where the row is in storage.
And that's really
why hotspotting
happens with Cloud
Spanner, because we
group rows that are next
to each other together
and store them on the same split
to allow for faster access.
And if you're always writing--
sequentially,
you're always going
to be writing to the
same node, as opposed
to allowing the system to
distribute that load evenly
across multiple nodes.
Last, backup and
disaster recovery.
We're always improving
in this area.
And the system obviously
takes system backups
and we handle high
availability and we
handle replication for you.
But in terms of
managed backup tools
that you might be familiar
with in your existing database,
we're working on that still.
Today, there's managed
export and import.
We take one hour of
historical data snapshots,
which it could go back to.
And we have a system-managed
backup service
coming very soon.
But it's a little bit
different than what
you might be expecting
compared to on-premise today.
So just something to think
about, but obviously not
an impediment to usage.
So some common
questions that we always
get around Cloud Spanner.
What's the replication delay?
You're moving data around the
world, around the country,
around the region.
This thing obviously
has to be slow.
And effectively,
there is no delay.
As soon as a
transaction commits,
reads from the replicas
will have the latest data.
And we guarantee that because
before you get the act back
or about your write,
that data has committed
to a quorum of the replicas.
So every replica knows
what is the latest
and if it has the latest data.
So you're guaranteed not
to get old or stale data
unless you want it.
As I mentioned, you can
get bounded stale reads,
in which case you're OK with
slightly out-of-date data.
In practicality, it's
a few milliseconds
with the replication delays, and
it's just seen as query latency
from the application.
The other question
that we often get
is when to use Cloud
Spanner versus Cloud
SQL versus Cloud Bigtable.
And this really comes
down to, what do
you want out of your database?
If you want a managed,
transactional, queryable,
infinitely scalable, no downtime
database, use Cloud Spanner.
If you need something
that's transactional,
queryable, you can tolerate
occasional maintenance
and downtime, but you're
willing to sacrifice
that for compatibility
with MySQL and PostgreS,
and you're OK with limited
scalability, limited headroom,
Cloud SQL is perfect for that.
And if you need
super low latency
and you're willing to
trade off queryability,
Cloud Bigtable is the database
or the data store for you.
And choosing between
the three of those
really comes down to
what are the unique needs
of your application
and what you need
to be able to accomplish
with your database.
Some additional questions.
This one always comes up.
Why is Cloud Spanner
so expensive?
And really, it's sort of
that initial sticker shock.
But once you start
to think through it
and compare Cloud Spanner
to other databases,
it's really not so
expensive, particularly
compared to on-premises.
And you have to think
about what you're getting
when you buy Cloud Spanner.
For the minimum
production configuration,
you're getting 6
terabytes of storage.
You're getting up to 30,000
QPS of reads, up to 6,000
QPS of writes.
Each node is
replicated three times.
So in a three-node
cluster, your data
is spread across nine nodes
and in three different zones.
And it's fully managed,
fully backed up, fully
replicated for you.
So you're getting a lot that's
all baked into that price.
It's just not broken out in
terms of buying a core thing
and then adding on
additional functionality.
It's all just one price.
The next question is, is
Cloud Spanner SQL compliant?
Yes, it's ANSI 2011
with extensions.
We support insert, update,
delete, select SQL statements.
It's very familiar
to folks moving
from traditional relational
databases to Cloud Spanner.
And then after saying
all of these things,
people often ask, is Cloud
Spanner really relational?
Yes, it is.
It provides strong consistency,
strongly typed schemas,
SQL queries with
INNER/OUTER JOIN.
And so it really is a
scalable relational database.
There are some philosophical
differences at its core
that change the
way that you have
to think through
using the database,
but it's still a
relational database.
It's still scalable.
It's still SQL-- all the
stuff that's familiar
and you're used to.
And it's part of a broader
portfolio of fully managed data
services.
So from all the way having
a managed in-memory data
service for Redis in Cloud
Memorystore to having
non-relational databases
in Cloud Datastore,
Cloud Firestore for mobile
applications, mobile web
and IT application
development, to Cloud Bigtable,
which is a wide column database
service for super low latency
data access.
And then on the
relational side, we
have Cloud SQL, which is
managed MySQL and PostgreS,
and Cloud Spanner,
which is what we've
been talking about
today in terms
of a scalable
relational database.
And then for object store,
we have Cloud Storage.
And for data
warehousing, we have
BigQuery, which is our
enterprise data warehouse
offering.
So I hope you enjoyed this talk.
I hope it was helpful in
terms of thinking through how
Cloud Spanner might be the
right tool for your application,
the right database
for your application.
I hope that you thought
this was helpful to think
through some of the
questions you might have.
And now please stay
tuned for a live Q&A.
We'll be back in
less than a minute.
Thank you.
Welcome back.
So we've got some
questions from the audience
that we're going to answer here.
So the first one is,
what's so special
about strong consistency?
And really, this
comes down to making
developers' lives easier.
If they can assume
strong consistency,
they can assume that
every read after a write
is the latest and greatest data.
And that just
makes life simpler.
There's a lot that's
been published
on even how eventual consistency
can lead to bugs and security
holes, but that's sort
of on the extreme end.
But at its core,
strong consistency
is just a nice aspect
to have for developers.
Developers that rely on
eventual consistency,
if they're building
multiple applications,
they have to solve
the problem of dealing
with eventual consistency
for every application,
whereas Cloud Spanner solves
that problem in the database.
So Cloud Spanner does
what databases do really
well in terms of storing
data and providing
the latest and greatest version
back to the application.
So the next question is,
why doesn't Cloud Spanner
have all the features
I'm used to having
in my on-prem database?
And so a lot of
on-prem databases
have been around
for 30 or 40 years.
So there's been
plenty of time, lots
of customer feedback in terms
of what features they want.
Also, philosophically,
these databases
are a little bit different.
These databases support
business logic in the database.
The database is in control.
With Cloud Spanner, the
application is in control.
And Cloud Spanner is just
there to store the data
and read/write the data.
Based on customer feedback
and customer input,
we are always adding new
features to Cloud Spanner.
So if you have a feature that
you really need, please let us
know.
We want to know
what you guys need,
particularly as you
modernize your applications
and move them to the
cloud, and use all of what
the cloud has to offer today.
The next question is, how
can I try out Cloud Spanner?
The easy answer there is to spin
up a Google Cloud free trial
and take a look
at Cloud Spanner.
While you can go look
at the pricing sheet
and you said, oh,
well, I'm not going
to be able to use
anything in production,
the free trial is more
than enough to go in
and play with Cloud Spanner
and start playing around.
Cloud Spanner is billed hourly.
So just because you go in
and create an instance,
doesn't mean that you're
going to get billed
for a month's worth of usage.
The next question is, when do
you use Bigtable versus Cloud
Spanner?
I touched on this a
little bit, but really,
it boils down to Bigtable is
for super high throughput,
low latency reads and writes.
And that's great for IoT data,
for streaming data, time series
data, for using as the back
end store for graph stores.
Bigtable makes a
lot of sense there.
It's scalable in the
same way Spanner is,
but when it replicates,
it's eventually consistent.
The replication across zones
is eventually consistent.
As well as it doesn't have
the sophisticated queryability
that Cloud Spanner does.
So everything in Bigtable is a
point lookup or a table scan,
whereas Cloud Spanner
gives you the SQL
queryability you'd expect
out of a relational database.
That being said, though, there
are a number of use cases
where Bigtable is
the right choice.
And it mostly has
to do with latency
and super high
throughput, where you just
need that blazing fast speed.
And so the last
question here is,
I have a custom application
that runs on legacy databases.
Can I migrate to Spanner?
Is Spanner full-fledged RDBMS?
And the short answer
is, yes, it is.
You can migrate.
It's not going to be just
a straight lift and shift.
In moving to Cloud
Spanner, you're
going to have to think
through, what are
the aspects in your database?
What's the business logic
that's in your database?
What are the queries you
have in your database?
You'll have to modernize
that a little bit.
But if you do have just
a simple application
and it has a simple
usage of a database,
there's no reason why
that wouldn't just
move to Cloud Spanner.
And then you can
optimize over time.
But we do see a lot of customers
that either think through
and take the time to modernize
as they move to Cloud Spanner,
or they lift and
shift to Cloud SQL
as a first step to get the
data into Google Cloud,
and then take the time
and take the opportunity
to move to Cloud Spanner
as their needs grow.
So those are all the
questions I have.
Please stay tuned for
the next session, which
is on how to enhance security
and privacy of your container
infrastructure.
Thank you so much
for joining today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]